[Musique]
à Verdun la vérité est que vous vous
êtes pas
occupé des gens que vous êtes moqués que
vous avez ri que vous avez dit que vous
ne prendriez pas le vaccin que ceux qui
ont été vaccinés se transformeraient en
alligators deviendrait homosexuel qu'il
ne doivent pas prendre le vaccin
personne dans l'histoire de tous les
gouvernements du monde n'a joué avec la
pandémie avec la mort comme vous l'avez
fait
quoi avec près de 690 000 décès le
Brésil est le deuxième pays le plus
touché au monde par la pandémie
l'opposition menée par Lula assure que
près de la moitié de ses morts aurait pu
être évité le président sortant tente de
son côté de briser l'image d'un loup la
présidente
vous parlez tellement des pauvres et je
tiens à ce que ce soit très clair au
cours de l'année 2020 lorsque les gens
ont été contraints de rester chez eux
non pas par mes décisions mais par celle
de nombreux gouverneurs membres de votre
partie ils allaient mourir de faim
et rien qu'en est d'urgence en 2020 nous
avons dépensé l'équivalent de 15 ans du
plan d'aide économique que vous aviez
créé
vainqueur avec 53% des voix mais les
instituts de sondage se sont lourdement
trompés au premier tour sous-estimant le
score de Jaïr bolsonaro de plus de 8
points
[Musique]